ei liberi un po d'acqua o ha messo a
fuoco
ma cosa vuol dire stato per diventare
bellissimo da baby sitter o super
divertente perché io sarò il padre devo
fare in modo che il bambino non muoia
non si faccia male v6 questo video quasi
10 mila mi piace farmi un altro bisogno
in cui sarò io il bambino vitale sarà il
baby sitter nuvolette devi con i premi
oscar
ecco allora eccomi qua io sono padre e
devo fare in modo che evita il bambino
rimanga in vita e non faccia qualche
disastro dove stai andando e mi sto solo
spostando qui un pochettino controllo è
poi ad aprile video scriveteci nei
commenti il times tabù dei momenti che
vi sono piaciuti più di tutti quindi il
minuto così qui andremo a rivedersi di
tutti rideremo stage in un'auto bruciata
governo guarda io prendo la figlia fosse
un aspirapolvere dove è fermo ma non
posso fare niente
ognuno già in fiore no ma no dai un
fiore fieri su verona che muori viola ma
ops il mio stomaco però fa un po male ma
ho visto là dentro non ti mando il mio
posto preferito non ti azzardare in
frigo non puoi andare in frigo
non posso dare conto è la mano gigante
chiudiamo il primo non mangiare le uova
crude
no forse non è stato fatto quasi mai
ferma tema fermo che io le mani
giocabili come combinato qua fermo 20 la
metti la non mangiare
no perché cristo mangia brics fermato
tirando le bottigliate
come faccio a prenderti o danno il
formaggio mazzo così ti facciano parere
su queste cose
nono posto per io ho non sono il motore
10 per cento devo darti composta da
mangiare altrimenti avrò perso sì la
nonna non questo devo andare su scelta
ma perché sto mangiando io dovevo
prenderli per te
ed ora dopo l'isola mi fa partire v.to
subito vita
mi raccomando spolli chat e perché si
parla e madrid voglio essere io il
babilée farlo impazzire allora cui
preghiamo c dove quella piccola peste
quanto sentito un rumore sospetto non mi
dire che una cosa non stanno giocando
piero la palla guarda 20 giorno appunto
come si muovevano da zero no no no non
usate l'aspirapolvere
[Musica]
ma mi hai fatto cadere a noi il vetro
loro loro non ho viaggiato il vetro è
mangiato il plesso pezzo di vetro il
pesce salvo il pesce metterlo nella
piscina nella piscina nella piscina
dietro casa ai salva pesciolini posso
prenderlo come si fa mentre quella stai
facendo mio fratello mi chiese di
stampare il paese perché volevi fare
qualcosa qua dove vai o no
ora claudio piron ora si può cercare di
tenere il bambino abitare bio di vita
possibile perché deve scadere il tempo
deve arrivare la mamma che cosa non ha
mai finita o non vuole benzina e facendo
ragazzini colaninno ha messo fuoco un
estintore
lo show sarà spinto arrivo di lavoro
come fatto aiuto l'estintore stint ore
ok io metto un po di sapore viviani come
si usa
mi sembrava bellissima e brava vero un
pelo non finiva votati bruciacchiati o
no cosa stai facendo
sto lavando si apre subito l'acqua così
vediamo che succede
aiuto che però è preso la scossa poi sta
negando collegando parte di basil ha
ferito io mi sto divertendo un sacco
pavimento non risco tedesco tino da
mangiare un biscottino biscotto non
riuscito con gilles jacob e cosa hai
mangiato la sera l'un per cento
volevo mangiare un biscotto così mi
riprendeva ovvero no non ce l'ho fatta e
ho vinto persona questa volta però era
né portando in cucina sì ma devo stare
super attenta e dove tenere dentro la
spazzatura
essi subito dai o mi sto muovendo con
tutto il bidone eh si come come faccio a
farti uscire non ho conosciuto mi sono
messo gioco
fatto mandarmi in soggiorno ma questo
giorno si o no te ne vai
il soggiorno che ho bisogno di aiuto le
più amate da fermo come faccio a
prenderti la fame lo sto mangiando tutto
se la pianta tavolino in e ora è qui c'è
un pezzo di sedia non è una scusa ma
primaverile maggio io allora perché cose
non vado a mangiare un uovo crudo ma non
mangia niente dal primo devo chiudere il
frigo no sono rimasto bloccato il frigo
adesso no no no no noi si defila ha
preferito che sta morendo vino ecco la
prima beta avrà e molto morire in frigo
non capisco se sono io che sono una
schiappa questo gioco oppure vitale
bravissimo a fare il bambino super
demoniaco sensi forte di riuscire a
nascondersi per falco lissimo parma devo
capire meglio come fare le varie azioni
tipo non riesco a prenderti in braccio
fra i presenti in braccio a toglierti
dalle cose oppure tardi da mangiare la
frutta qualcosa e cosa stai mangiando
queste proprio bob invitare che va a
mangiare tutto fermo non si mangiano le
uova crude o no chiudiamo il frigo nome
preso l'uomo libero now
no noi trevor riuscire a tenerti in vita
per più tempo possibile
ok ora mangio io queste uova no a sei
stai male se mangi quelle uova ma almeno
tu rimarrà in vita
sai che io non fermate per tu stai male
io sto male
e in effetti allora sto bevendo un
quest'ultima data lo zombie
cerca di avere mangiato tutto quelle
uova il cavallo ha detto rispetto
provo a mangiare una frutta e una
bottiglietta da e v7 meglio distrutto e
mangiare frutta
sì anche se sono ancora un po verde
liberi un po d'acqua pari a bambino
evitare il sopportabile udrih mangiato
ha avuto una fetta di carne cruda
[Applauso]
eccoci qua questa volta devo stare super
attenta vediamo dove spesso è vitale
dove vive nascosta o non lo so non mi
dire che sei un sito non giro oggi in
giardino o no ma è pieno di peri eccolo
vado è vicino e azzardare in erba
ok questo al sicuro ed è forse ci sono
meno pericoli qua la piscina è chiusa
bene usa la faceva dove stai andando
affatto dalla piscina fermo non ti
azzardare dervisi collo e non di aiutare
napoli non entrò prima io non ho mai per
fortuna votare salvo che devo vincere io
da dov'è finito i costi sono braccioli
no veramente volevo darle a te
ciao a una pac come no fermo benvenuto a
fare qualcosa
queste cose forse mi potrebbe aiutare e
che cosa farà certo all'ansa come arma
dai guarda che io salto ma un fermo
bloccato che non si muove tanto per
trattare dai fermo attento che fai
affogando no no io alla ciambella sono
pronta a prendere pivot che allora salto
sopra di te
enzo mac sono salate e sono io ma sono
fuori dall'acqua non riesco ad andare
dunque che è pronta una tabella dove
guarda mi tocca salvarmi da solo che
cos'è la visita dove dove dov'è eccoti
dai sono qui ma che bravo io a notare
leader ma ti rendi conto subito acqua
sono dovuto salvare da solo dove niente
è stato l'altro succede arrivare un
minuto un minuto dai siti tempo in video
per minuto proibito sicura di riuscirci
dove sei
aiuto aiuto dov'è finito il tetto della
casa sul tetto o tentate entra sta
accadendo in piscina e un regalo in
piscina no no no
scusami ma devo vincere ma guarda sono
tutti vedi mi vedi eccoti dove vita ma
ti rendi conto che io sono a caldo è
giusto per annegare
no come faccio a prendermi vabbè ma ho
capito io scendo dico ciao
anche questo finalmente ti sei liberato
di una ciambella ecco sono riuscita hai
vinto tu come fatto la nostra ultima
partita siamo 3 a 1 devo vincere questa
partita assolutamente quindi sono
sporcato un pochettino io volevo fare un
giro nel vostro figlio
no da ricordare guarda perché no no
chiudi via marconi dai no tav i no
perché di questa povera sia perché ho
mangiato l'aspirapolvere lanciato da
stiro porto lotti su che cosa in bocca
ma sentono davvero non sono stato io no
togli lascia quella padella sul mito si
crede pietro il papa nella quale aspetto
che ciò anche l'olio aiuta il frullatore
aspetto sono entrato un fondatore
comunque se fare o no no no no no no
essi sono cipur frullatore allora
vediamo qua la cucina
non ce la faccio più a fare accendere la
cucina saliti a 11 togliti togliti
togliti togliti come si spegne così
concessi formarli rubinetto devo aprire
il rubinetto lo apro io ho vinto però
messo a fuoco la cucina va bene questo
era il gioco fusione di a smettere di
santo farò tutto in estiva per dinara
perde anche se mi fate esaurito
rivendicare che farei è bambino
voglio sperare quindi nostra tu prendi
piace questo possa servire anche
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccando su quella che preferite
buona visione ciao